[Musique]
bonsoir oui mais non mais je suis arrivé
là ouais il une erreur parce qu'on a
recommandé
c'est peut-être face à non mais à bombay
mais je te présente françois ou merde
moi je suis français je suis pas chez
moi martelait que ce pas oui ça se voit
pas tout de suite
il a expliqué les origines son enfant
c'est le moment ces moments de quoi tu
as fait ton père était quand même le sol
chinois qui on parvient dans le
troisième elle regarde mon pote on c'est
grandiose chinatown comtois ton cousin
un petit quelque chose mais je me
rappelle plus c'est le mec qui affectait
le même style
bon allez c'est quoi l'histoire avec ton
père je devais à obéir sans partir alors
je me suis barré tu crois pas de
séquelles mais en dix piges il a aussi
besoin de parler avec lui le puits pas
trop profond cinq ans
trop court
j'ai pas compris moi non plus je ne
comprends jamais du coup tu fais oui oui
comme ça j'aimerais reprendre des cours
de chinois ring pour mieux comprendre
tout relax entre ces traits l'ami de
sion de questions expliqué pourquoi te
rappelles fillon ça veut dire héros en
français ça veut dire autre chose c'est
gros c'est ton père tu j'ai dit el papa
mais mes visites je pas le forcer non
plus on pourrait peut-être attendre que
le bébé inès toi
[Musique]
ton père pense aux bébés mais tu as peur
de quoi mais ça va bien se passer
quelque chose à dire
un problème avec la nourriture de l'âme
vous demander justement c'était quoi
seuil ou qui sait quoi c'est du chien
bon j'ai pas de chance à des gens de
céder quand même